vielen dank guten morgen meine damen und
herren die wehrbeauftragte eva högl
stellt ihren jahresbericht vor und
dieser bericht gibt den stand der
bundeswehr aus dem jahre 2021 wieder eva
högl kommt darin zum schluss dass die
streitkräfte dringend modernisiert
werden müssen es fehlt an vielem zum
beispiel an persönlicher
schutzausrüstung die hauptwache systeme
sind teilweise nicht einsetzbar und die
infrastruktur teils völlig marode da ist
es gut dass der bundeskanzler eine
zeitenwende ausgerufen hat und mit den
100 milliarden die der bundeswehr zur
verfügung gestellt werden sollen da
lässt sich sicherlich das eine oder
andere machen aber eins muss man auch
festhalten im moment wäre die bundeswehr
sicherlich nur bedingt einsatzfähig wenn
es darum ginge dieses land zu
verteidigen und darüber will ich
sprechen heute morgen mit meinen beiden
gästen und ich begrüße wolfgang hellmich
und ali al alami das sind die beiden
verteidigungspolitischen sprecher der
spd und der linken
helmig fangen wir mit ihnen an also ich
habe es gesagt viele mängel das ist so
üblich beim berberich dieses mal guckt
man besonders darauf aufgrund auch der
aktuellen situation
und wenn frau hügel ihre kolleginnen die
ehemals aus dem bundestag feststellt
dass bundeswehrsoldaten und sogar noch
nichtmals schutzausrüstung haben und
teilweise in den einsatz solcher
ausrüstungen nachgeschickt werden da
muss man schon fragen die bundeswehr ist
eine parlamentsarmee
das sind unter unhaltbare zustände was
werden sie dagegen tun
also die zustände sind nicht neu und wir
arbeiten sondern denen ja schon seit
einigen jahren deshalb ist ja im laufe
der letzten jahre bis jetzt auf 50,3
milliarden der einzelplan 14 der
verteidigungshaushalt auch bestehen um
genau an diesen stellen auch mit
beschleunigung daran zu gehen die
bundeswehr ausrüstung zu können auch die
vorherigen wehrbeauftragten haben da den
finger daher schon nennen die wunde
gelegt damit wieder schneller werden und
damit fahren die soldatinnen soldaten
das material das sie brauchen
bekommen und deshalb nicht nur geld rein
tun sondern wir müssen auch die prozesse
beschleunigen in denen in der
beschaffung dann in sehr langen
abständen in schutzausrüstung zb bis 20
31 beschafft werden sollte das geht so
natürlich nicht und mit diesen 100
milliarden kommen schneller machen aber
wir mussten auch die prozesse
beschleunigen also die bürokratischen
fragen müssen angegangen werden das sind
kommunizierende röhren da muss dem koran
und den ministerien tut das
wenn wir mal drauf schauen die frau hat
auch gesagt 77 prozent ungefähr ist die
bundeswehr einsatzfähig fand das sogar
einen relativ hohen wert wäre denen die
bundeswehr ihrer meinung nach in der
aktuellen lage in der lage unser land zu
verteidigen naja frau hügel hat auch
einmal gesagt dass die bundeswehr
einsatzbereit ist ich glaube zunächst
einmal die feststellung im wehrbericht
zeigen eklatante lücken auf das muss man
einfach feststellen hellmich hatte ja
schon richtigerweise darauf hingewiesen
dass diese nicht neu sind ich will aber
trotzdem konstatieren dass wir nicht
glauben dass 100 milliarden einfach ich
sag jetzt mal in das schwarze loch wäre
da die situation maßgeblich verändern
werden ich bin nur einige beispiele
nennen wir haben den haushalt im beta
verdoppelt in den letzten 20 jahren
trotzdem ist es so dass die beschaffung
nicht funktioniert und wenn sie
funktioniert dann in einem maßstab
dennis modellen ist die sport funkgeräte
die bundeswehr die soldatinnen und
soldaten arbeiten mit funkgeräten aus
den 80er jahren und anstatt neue modelle
zu beschaffen hat man einfach 30.000
nachbildungen organisiert gefechts allen
wir sind immer noch nicht flächendeckend
vergeben schutzausrüstung müssen
soldatinnen und soldaten selber kaufen
all das sind probleme die trotzdem
bestehen trotz der verdopplung des
wetters in den letzten 20 jahren deshalb
meinen wir 100 milliarden werden dass
substanzielle probleme schließen wir
müssen an die ursachen gehen und das ist
das beschaffungswesen und das ist die
art wie hier mit den geldern umgegangen
werden aber er hält mich woran liegt das
dass die verschiedenen
verteidigungsminister und ministerin
nicht in den griff kriegen die probleme
sind ja seit eigentlich jahrzehnten die
gleichen wir haben zu lange und so
komplizierte prozesse sehr bürokratisch
aufgebaut
und haben möglichkeiten die es gibt in
der vergangenheit nicht genutzt ich
nehme ein beispiel aus rahmenverträgen
geld abzurufen und damit sehr schnell ob
es schaffung auszulösen oder die
möglichkeiten des europäischen rechts
zum nutzen den § 346 in den details die
möglichkeiten zu nutzen um auch direkt
selbst beschaffen zu können zum beispiel
keine ausschreibung machen zu müssen
wenn es diesen bedarf der bundes ergibt
darauf wurde in der vergangenheit
verzichtet
jetzt wird dieses instrument auch
eingepackt und wie gesagt tempo drauf zu
bringen weil das ziel ist am ende
schneller die dinge offen hof im hafen
und männer stehen zu haben und nicht in
welchen prozessen zu sagen man muss da
ein satz zu sagen die bundeswehr ist mit
260.000 menschen der größte arbeitgeber
der bundesrepublik
das ist eine große menge an menschen die
ausgerüstet werden müssen und das ist
auch eine große menge menschen die zum
geld kosten deshalb sind die meere
nimweger in den letzten jahren auch in
diesem haushalt aufgefressen worden
seien möglich kosten für die erhaltung
des alten materials und das obwohl ich
das richtig in neuss zu investieren als
in altes immer weiter an zu stecken was
aber auch die aufgaben erfüllt
das bundesamt für wehrtechnik in koblenz
6500 bundeswehr beamte andere beamte die
dort alles verwalten eine anschaffung
über 1000 euro und aufwärts muss dort
verwaltet werden warum bekommt man das
sich hin griff muss das nicht radikal
reformiert werden hat es muss absolut
radikal reformiert werden weil du das
problem ist wie sie selbst ja vorhin
festgestellt haben seit jahrzehnten
bekannt und das problem ist wie gesagt
nicht neu und führt natürlich dazu dass
wir immer größeren frustration grad auch
bei den soldatinnen und soldaten
bekommen das müssen wir doch auch
feststellen wir sind eine
parlamentsarmee und wir haben die
verantwortung dafür sorge zu tragen dass
die soldatinnen und soldaten so gut
ausgerüstet sind wie sie wie möglich und
das ist de facto nicht der fall und das
habe ich vorhin schon erwähnt an welchen
fällen dass das haupt aber es hat auch
damit zu tun dass wir aufträge vergeben
die sehr kurios anmuten ist nur das
beispiel heckler & koch liefert für über
250 millionen euro sturmgewehre den ich
gerade ausschließen und thekla und koch
muss dafür nicht geradestehen weil die
verträge so ausgestaltet worden sind
dass sie aus der haftung entlassen
worden sind und das sind exakte probleme
und darüber müssen wir offen reden und
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass wir
irgendwie gegen die soldaten und
soldaten sind wir darüber offen redet
will dass sich die verhältnisse
verändern und die soldatinnen und
soldaten die bestmögliche ausrüstung
ausrüstung bekommen richtig weil es
gerade eine parlamentsarmee ist das ist
ja auch im interesse natürlich der
abgeordneten jetzt ist ja noch schlimmer
herr hellmich das in internationalen
einsätzen die bundeswehrsoldaten
teilweise ja wie die trottel darstellen
zb im baltikum hat frau höhe geraten
beispiel wenn man vom letzten jahr das
ist noch nicht von diesem jahr da sind
wir sogar truppenführer quasi und unsere
soldaten können mit den dortigen
funkgeräten nicht umgehen das ist doch
zutiefst peinlich
weil das gerade auch gekommen ist wir
haben funkelte beschafft um im einsatz
der nato um in unseren bündnispartnern
kommunizieren zu können weil die sind
nicht alle durch digitalisiert hätten
wir diese nicht gekauft hätten wir in
den einsätzen gar nicht miteinander
kommunizieren können und deshalb werden
wir jetzt diese systeme die alten
gemeinsam in der nato bild digitale
systeme abgelöst und deshalb muss man
immer noch sagen wir arbeiten den
kontext der nato werden bekannt dass mit
unseren bündnispartnern
die uns auch aufgaben in der nato zu
schreiben dass wir zu liefern was wir zu
tun haben deshalb wissen wir dass eine
beispiel dass die organe genannt haben
aufgreifen mit den ausschreibungen oder
verwaltung 1000 euro jetzt setzen wir
diesen diese summe auf 5000 euro rauf da
meint man ist ja nicht viel aber das
bundesamt in koblenz und nicht einmal
die machen eine gute arbeit das darf ich
kann zwar verdammt aufkommen lassen die
haben aber jedes jahr 3300
beschaffungsprozesse von klein bis groß
und dadurch dass wir diese summe auch
setzen setzt werden erheblichen teil
auch an arbeitskraft frei die sich dann
nicht mehr mit dem klein-klein befassen
müssen sondern dann in den großen
projekten da ans werk gehen können weil
das bundesamt in koblenz ist personell
unterbesetzt und
dann muss man an diesen stellen diesen
eckpunkten glaub anpacken und das tut
das bundesamt das tut aus das
ministerium unter wie gesagt mit dem
voranzubringen
lange als ich zur bundeswehr muss den
80er jahren da war die bundeswehr noch
eine armee für die landesverteidigung
dann ist es mehrfach nach der
wiedervereinigung geändert worden und
viele sagen es fehlt so eine strategie
gerade im moment fragt man natürlich was
kann die bundeswehr eigentlich könnte
sie uns verteidigen gleichzeitig stehen
wir in mehreren auslandseinsätzen
übernehmen wir uns nicht auch mit der
truppenstärke die wir haben und auch mit
den intakten waffen denn das ist eine
katastrophe wie vor groß gerät nicht
funktioniert das tun wir natürlich und
das sehen wir auch an den
auslandseinsätzen die stattfinden wie
klappt die lücken dort sind und wie
problematisch sich diese einsätze
gestalten ich glaube es hängt
miteinander zusammen kein band eine
beendigung der auslandseinsätze ist die
grundlage dafür dass die bundeswehr
überhaupt im kern ihres auftrages
wahrnimmt und dass es die
landesverteidigung ich lehne diese
auslandseinsätze ab stichwort jetzt mali
wo wir derzeit sind und wo die
bundeswehr im einsatz ist diese einsätze
sind einfach gescheitert wir sind im
schlepptau frankreichs dorthin gegangen
die damals im schlepptau der usa in
afghanistan in afghanistan zogen sich
die usa zurück die bundesregierung stand
da dasselbe erleben wir jetzt mit
frankreichs die ziehen sich aus mali
zurück und die unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten stehen jetzt einfach auch da
und die bundesregierung hat keinen plan
und deshalb sagen wir raus aus den
auslandseinsätzen
sensation auf die landesverteidigung und
die bestmögliche ausrüstung dafür für
die soldatinnen und soldaten
wäre das nicht eine klare ansage für die
bundeswehr frau lamprecht die neue
verteilt ministerin hat mehrfach auf
fragen gesagt also sie will keine große
reform angehen sondern mehr kleine
schritte an kleineren stellen reparieren
ist das das richtige vorgehen also es
gab mal einen bundesminister der
verteidigung
der hat im plenarsaal wir standen gesagt
hätte während an der bundeswehrreform
jeden dienstposten einmal angefasst und
mehrzad aber wenn ich in meinem
unternehmen jede arbeitsplatz einmal
verändern würde wenn man unternehmen
kaputt
und deshalb war diese reform die dort
angegangen worden ist wie folgt vor ende
vollzogen es letztendlich das auflösen
von funktionierenden strukturen
innerhalb der bundeswehr eine große
strukturreform eine große
bedeutet dass die bundeswehr sich über
jahre mit strukturreform prozessen
beschäftigt und befasst das braucht sie
nicht sondern sie muss sie darauf
ausrichten das zu tun was von mir
verlangt wird
ein bisschen im ausland afghanistan sind
wir maßlos gescheitert andere auch sie
ist eigentlich nicht in der lage zur
landesverteidigung es gibt keine vbk es
mehr wie das früher der fall war also im
im land es ist doch nicht genau zu
erkennen wenn man sich nicht täglich
damit beschäftigt dafür steht diese
bundeswehr wir brauchen noch kann der
neuen verwaltungsstrukturen aber wir
haben das ziel im jahr 2025 eine voll
digitalisierte division der nato auch
bei der übernahme der wtf zur verfügung
zu stellen nicht 2027 sondern vorgezogen
auf 20 25 dass das material das das
personal das heißt digital kommunizieren
und funken können das sind neu
satellitentechnologie gegen die
materielle ausrüstung die
schutzausrüstung und dieses alles gehört
dazu dass er auf das ergebnis kommt es
an und nicht auf ellenlange prozesse und
das ergebnis erzielt werden zb diese
voll ausgestattete die vision 2025 ist
ja kein
geheimnis dass ihre fraktionen gegen
diese 100 milliarden sind ihnen das
wären wir sicherlich auch gleich wieder
in den reden hören aber wenn man
tatsächlich mal den ausrüstungsstand der
bundeswehr anguckt und sie haben gerade
gesagt die bundeswehr sollte sich auf
ihren kernauftrag konzentrieren viele in
diesem land zweifeln daran dass die
deutsche bundeswehr zum beispiel einen
russischen angriff zurückschlagen könnte
wie kann man dann verantworten dass man
sagt die bundeswehr hat ja jetzt schon
viel geld die braucht nicht mehr geld
auch wenn geld weg sichert und diese wir
haben ja über koblenz schon gesprochen
dass er sicherlich ein problem ist also
keiner der regierungsvertreter konnte
mir bisher sagen warum es frankreich mit
einer ähnlichen militär gelingt ja eine
gut ausgerüstete ausgestattete armee zu
haben die diese probleme die wir kennen
in dieser form überhaupt nicht bekannt
ist dass zum ersten zum zweiten ist es
so die letzten jahrzehnte sind geld da
dort schon rhein geflossen wir reden ja
immer über jährliche haushaltsetat von
über 50 milliarden jetzt einfach mal
konkret machen wenn wir jetzt die 100
milliarden dazunehmen übrigen gibt es
ein demokratiedefizit weil das an dem
haushalt des verteidigungsausschusses
vorbeigeht die beschaffung also die
atombombe wurden nicht im
haushaltsausschuss gestern beschlossen
dass das ein demokratiedefizit welches
ist sie es will aber sagen dass wären
theoretisch 20 milliarden jährlich
zusätzlich aus diesen 100 milliarden
topf wir werden also bei über 70
milliarden wir wären also der
zweitgrößte hätten das zweitgrößte
militärischer der welt wir hätten in
europa den größten militär etat und ich
finde das ist überdimensioniert nicht
verhältnismäßig und noch mal das geld
ist da es wird wirklich nicht ordentlich
eingesetzt und über 50 milliarden sollen
nicht dafür ausreichend über jahre
übrigens immer wieder dass die
bundeswehr gut ausgestattetes ist sage
das macht deutlich dass das eklatante
fehler gibt die man mit mehr geld nicht
lösen wird da ist ja was dran die
israelische armee zum beispiel der hat
prozentual gesehen viel weniger geld zur
verfügung als dass die bundeswehr jetzt
schon hat und sie ist trotzdem hoch
effizient woran liegt das herr hellmich
sie ist weniger sie ist wesentlich
kleiner
das ein oder andere punkt weil sozusagen
prozentual sich verfügt auch in der
veltener breite nicht über die
fähigkeiten über die wir verfügen
hier unten ganz anders arsenal- auch von
fähigkeiten an der armee die israelische
armee ist auf diese auseinandersetzung
in ihrem land mit ihren nachbarn
ausgerichtet wir sind wesentlichen heute
in ein bündnis aufgestellt waren ist in
diesen fähigkeiten unterhalten und auch
in die nato ein liefern und deshalb sind
die relationen bei uns auf was die
massen system angeht andere sie sind nur
verteidigungspolitiker bei der linken
aber wenn man mit nicht
verteidigungspolitikern der linken
spricht dann sagen die weg mit dem
ganzen geld eigentlich brauchen wir auch
keine bundeswehr und sie sagen ja auch
sehr häufig also jetzt in dem konflikt
um gottes willen wir müssen verhandeln
bloß keine waffen dahin geben wie soll
das funktionieren wollen sie an putin am
grünen tisch überreden kommen dass man
eine waffenruhe das sind zwei paar
schuhe also programmatisch sind wir für
eine verteidigungsarmee dass die
bundeswehr ihren auftrag erfüllt
natürlich in der pluralistischen partei
wegen der anderen gibt es auch dort
andere position und die nehme ich zur
kenntnis dass waffenlieferungen angeht
ich befürchte dass je weiter wir diese
eskalationsspirale mitmachen und nichts
anderes ist ja schweren waffen zu
liefern umso eher kommen wir in die
situation über jahre einen dauernden
abnutzungs und stellungskrieg in europa
zu bekommen uns bleibt doch auf lange
ist es noch nicht übrig mit normalen
menschenverstand als irgendwann doch
miteinander zu reden und zu verhandeln
um irgendwie die waffen zum stillstand
zu bringen und irgendwie den
verhandlungs motors zu bekommen und es
wurde ja vorhanden zwischen der ukraine
und russland jetzt ist es wieder
ausgesetzt worden also wir müssen wie
ich finde auch aus der historischen
abwägung alles dafür tun dass wir zum
frieden kommen zum dialog und zur
entspannung und nicht weiter waffen in
eskalationsspirale schieben die jetzt
schon laufen vielen dank herr al dailami
hellmich dass sie bei uns waren